I'm going to show you a portion of my
library of books for learning languages
in order to illustrate the point that
variety is so essential when it comes to
learning a language and this means
varying your activities varying your
sources so for example when I started
into Russian I have one two three four
five Beginner Books for Russia more or
less covers the same material in five
different formats and this was the case
for all the languages that I have
learned largely the same material from
different Vantage points until I could
graduate to books targeting the native
speaker I even go back and read grammar
books at some point I even looked at
learning Ukrainian using polish or
learning polish using Ukrainian so vary
what you do and at different stages of
your learning make sure you vary your
sources of content and the nature of
your activities